what are your thoughts on uh this whole
joe rogan controversy that's been
happening the last couple i thought it
was interesting they gave him a hard
time but it goes to show you how they
are really behind him and they really
respect him you know because if it was
anybody else even a step underneath him
rap it'd have been over
like in terms of like
obviously he's had a very successful
podcast you have a successful podcast
um
he's kind of looked at as like someone
who's helped a lot of comedians with his
platform over the years i'm quite sure
he has yeah i'm i'm going to matter back
i'm going to try to get on joe rogan
this year but
um
you can't miss him because his name is
everywhere even before the the the word
end the letter n in the kovic situation
i just believe unless you're a doctor i
think it should stay away from kovic
issues um
i mean the tape is the tape but the tape
is the tape
why isn't the tape um
used against this person when you have
the tape here's a different story
but there's tape but you have tape you
see it
so is there anything it can't be good
for you one person not good for the
other person right do you think like
cause because my thing is is like do you
think
you know i think that me and james
talked about this just in in general any
use of the n-word is out if you're not a
black person yeah absolutely it's a code
right
we could use it there are certain like
comedians you can use it around your
friends but not to well like there's
like certain guys like louis c.k who's
used it
like right in front of chris rock that
one time on hbo thing um is there any
sort of like
rule rule with the comedian [ __ ] like
does comedy leave it wide open if
there's a certain context involved you
think yeah because i say [ __ ] all the
time i mean but you you can say that
yeah i say [ __ ] all the time um
but believe it or not when i get off
stage i don't use profanity at all at
all at all i don't curse at all when i'm
off stage
we live in a strange time man
you know the world changed that's why
bill cosby got caught up right the world
changed it was like he committed the
crime today mm-hmm the world changed he
still happened to be still alive and got
caught up in in the bs
right so
it comes you know they said you're going
high but so long what caught up with
them
do you think someone like joe rogan
should be cancelled or quote unquote
cancer he should be cancer but because
he didn't get cancer you look like a
fool saying he should get cancer when he
stood the storm right um what's my man
the rock yeah that was against him
because everybody thought
everyone came after the rock
and then the rock retracted his stance
so he did retract yeah
well because originally he had posted in
support of him right but then i'm saying
he did he retracted after the last one
no he retracted i think his support for
jordan right right right put a tweet out
pretty much saying just like hey now i
know the full narrative right right
right and it still doesn't take away
from because there's a tape there's yes
right see i see they could say that
see if there wasn't a tape
again
this conversation would be different
then you could say oh he's not racist
but you saw the tape
so even though when you first seen it
even though even even though we
have a tendency to overreact
society overreacts online especially
nowadays right especially nowadays we
overreact and
joe is a nice i'm quite sure he's not
known but i'm quite sure is the
overreaction i didn't see the tape
everything i'm hearing talk about right
now is just really hearsay but i do know
there was a tape and i i just want the
tape to be consistent with everybody
right
if i saw you doing something on the tape
that's the tape like it can't be good
for you but then something else happens
right it's not good for you i think
that's wrong that's fair that should be
just a general rule for it just a
general rule it has to be fair for
everybody but we know i i
even in my act i teach people not to be
chilled you know you ever walk in the
room and someone gives you a bigger
candy say oh well we that's the black
community
because when whites do something they
say oh he didn't get the same case etc
right but i tell people time that if you
read the um
the law library and if you're in jail
if a black man and white man is arrested
it states in the book
that a white man can't get the same
charge as a black man
i mean that's something we've obviously
just seen right yeah yeah it's just is
is deep but um
what i try to teach people is just the
way the world right and like even when
they talk about racism say i believe
racism will always exist
i think people can't get along right but
we can respect each other see there's a
difference i mean we may like each other
but i'm still going to be if people
start saying this in racism
we're never going to end that that's
impossible because that's
a very unrealistic it's unrealistic but
we can respect each other
i can respect you
you can do that
see so they need to change it to
we're going to respect each other then
say let's end racism
i think it changes the whole game
yeah i think ending racism is a great
thought right right it sounds like all
cotton candy but it's when there's so
many variables so many where are you
where you might be raised
you were raised um no matter what
everyone has a certain amount
of prejudice that is even subconscious
yes right they're just sitting there but
that doesn't mean that like your hate
like they're like i think everyone has a
certain amount of uh subconscious
stereotype about people yes or prejudice
about people like you said it's a matter
of respect it's a matter of like
are you a hateful person right are you
and see you can still be hateful
that's how powerful respect is
respect is so powerful that i could
still i could hate the [ __ ] out you
but i respect you so much you know
michelle